if you marry your virgin stay with each
other 10 years 15 years just like you
said I feel like when your partner goes
to work because they haven't had enough
experience they need to get out their
system and because they haven't got out
of the system they're going to get out
their system 20 years later they're not
you're not completely wrong because you
know some women get engrossed in the
culture so you can you can have her not
have any sexual partners before but she
still sees the girls out in the club she
still sees the city you know the city
life so it happens to some girls but
like on a balance of probabilities
what's what's what's better a girl with
100 Partners or a girl with zero
yeah yeah yeah and so does that happen
yeah sure